the war in ukraine has not gone as
expected
keeve was meant to fall to russian
invaders in a matter of days
three months after missiles shells and
paratroopers began landing in and around
the capital
ukraine is putting the spoils of war on
display
morale and anger at russia are now so
high ukrainians say the only acceptable
victory will be taking everything back
occupied territories in the east even
crimea
yes i believe the return of our
territories is possible and i think we
should not stop i believe there should
not be any negotiations about returning
to the same borders we had before the
start of this war
no
we should get our cities and crimea back
this is our sovereign country and we
should defend it there should not be any
negotiations with the enemy
of course i believe full stop i hope
that it will be this way the truth is on
our side we are defending our land we
really want and hope for this to happen
yes ukraine need weapons and
our our army will will do everything and
we will win
i'm not i'm sure
we will get
victory
and
yes who will win
there was less optimism when all-out war
came to ukraine on february 24th
russian president vladimir putin's
so-called special military operation
was the biggest assault on a european
state since world war ii
the u.n estimates at least 14 million
people have been displaced so far at
least six million to neighboring
countries
when missiles hit a ukrainian army base
in yavariv near the border with nato
member poland it was the furthest
russian attack in the west of the
country
the siege of mario pole so violent it
wiped the city off the map leaving
little doubt as to how far russia was
willing to go to achieve its aims
unable to penetrate ukrainian defenses
around the capital russia's withdrawal
from bucha revealed civilian killings
that ukraine described as war crimes
a dramatic victory for ukrainians the
sinking of russia's lead warship in the
black sea russia blamed an onboard
ammunition explosion ukrainians claimed
it was a missile strike
the invasion did change the map but not
perhaps as putin had hoped
finland and sweden applying to join nato
stands to more than double the
alliance's border with russia
just weeks ago independence square was
under lockdown and covered in snow
now people line up to buy stamps
commemorating a moment in the early days
of the war
when ukraine in no uncertain terms told
russia to leave its territory
i hope that is a good sign that
we can win in this war and we can
survive
so for me it's a sign that we have a
chance for a good future and you have a
message for russia and russian leaders
do you have a message
only but words i'm sorry i can't say
anything also i can say
things look very different in the
ukrainian capital today diplomatic
missions are reopening people are
returning and ukrainians seem far more
optimistic albeit cautiously than they
did at the beginning of this war
but the war is not over russian forces
are escalating offensives in ukraine's
east re-mobilizing forces to
battlefields in the south all
indications are conflict with russia is
the new normal
and as long as russia controls the skies
over their country
nowhere in ukraine is completely safe
theirs is a future that remains
uncertain
well let's now speak to zayn he joins us
from kiev zayn i see we've also had even
more strong rhetoric from president
zolensky
that's exactly right well i'll start
with a
senior security official
who spoke to our team on background um
was telling us that there is ongoing
activity in the east that is where the
conflict is flaring up most at this
point in time but military strategists
for the ukrainians are looking at
activities in the south in the coastal
areas at ports protecting odessa trying
to take back terrain that they've lost
in the south they say that is where
ukraine's
battles will be won or lost when it
comes to pushing back against the
russians and that is uh what is key at
the moment but he said all of that
amounts to the fact that this will
continue to be a long drawn-out conflict
president vladimir zelinski in his most
recent statements really echoed remarks
of his military leadership saying
announcing
another tragic incident nowhere near the
east or the south this took place in a
place called desna in the trinity region
north of kiev close to the belarusian
border
last week there was a missile strike and
only just yesterday did rescue workers
complete their digging of the rubble of
a building that was destroyed 87 people
he said were killed in that attack he
announced also that there had been uh
1400 plus missile strikes thousands of
missiles have been dropped
at least as many aerial bombardments by
russian helicopters and planes and he
says they primarily target civilian
infrastructure
he also said there was a bloodbath
happening in the east what's happening
in the donbass region is some of the
worst military atrocities committed
against ukraine by russia and he
basically said that russia is raising to
the ground the very same areas that they
pledged to liberate when they started
this conflict uh now ukraine's foreign
minister uh meeting his u.s counterpart
shortly after that he announced that
there will be more heavy u.s weaponry
heading into ukraine to try to change
the narrative in the donbass region that
could include what we've heard of
reports of potentially 90 u.s howitzers
uh making their way to the fight and
that is something that could certainly
change the tide of this war in ukraine's
favor especially in the east of the
country zayn bizravi there on the ground
for us in kiev thanks so much zayn
well let's now